do you agree with the Steve Baker should
Dominic Cummings resign well I think
what we heard in the last 24 hours
suggests some quite serious allegations
against the Prime Minister's chief
adviser and I think people are feeling
rightly angry millions of people have
has put their lives on hold have made
huge sacrifices to obey the rules during
this period and we've seen the
heartbreak of people not being able to
attend funerals of loved ones not being
able to see their family members as they
die and I think people are rightly
feeling is it one rule for us and one
rule for the people at the top and I
think there are questions to ask both in
terms of what Dominic Cummings Fiat but
also in terms of the response that we
saw yesterday where we seem to get this
rowing back of the rules from minister
after minister suggesting that nothing
had been done incorrectly I think we all
heard the Prime Minister very seriously
at the start of this lockdown saying
stay at home at the NHS save lives and
that's what people did and if we hadn't
have done it we wouldn't have brought
those infection rates down and we
wouldn't have the lowering of the death
rate that we're now seeing as people are
rightly angry and the Prime Minister I
think needs to come the press conference
today and answer questions about what
happened what he knew and what he's
going to do without it so yeah Boris
Johnson to front of that press
conference but just to be clear you
don't seem to be calling for dominant
Congress to resign we need some really
serious for me a minute you look at the
office of the Prime Minister questioning
and undermining statements from our
police force in Durham this is very
serious and we need to understand what
happened and we need to cut through
anger that we're all feeling
understandably about this we've had the
highest death rate in Europe there are
people suffering and people making huge
sacrifices good
and here we have a situation where
somebody whose family have had symptoms
travels halfway across the country
potentially going back and forth again
thereafter as well with the new
allegations that we've seen this morning
we've written to mark said well the
cabinet secretary to say can you
investigate this because you know
undermining the police breaking the
rules is if it's a very serious business
and we need answers and we need the
prime minister who come to the press
conference today and explain what has
happened we were talking to you gone
chaps later on the program to put the
government side of the story but the
Dominic Cummings defense seems to be
that he was worried about his child at a
time when his wife was ill with
coronavirus he later came down with co19
as well and do you have sympathy with
that we all have sympathy with everybody
in this situation because it's been
really stressful and really difficult I
know
single mums who've had a ovid when their
child has had to stay with them and
we've had to ship in food to make sure
they can eat everyone has made
incredible sacrifices we think of
Ishmael the thirteen-year-old boy whose
parents didn't attend his funeral after
he died on his own if everybody had
decided to break the rules then we
wouldn't have brought this infection
rate down and when we heard the Prime
Minister we heard him say stay at home
take the NHS save lives
he didn't say or dry 260 miles to Durham
if you think that's the right thing to
do that that broadens what we heard and
that wasn't what was said and that
wasn't what everybody else did and
that's why we need answers Dominic
Cummings clearly a huge story this
morning and but I'm also keen to ask you
quickly about something that I know that
many parents are going to be concerned
about and that is whether or not schools
should be reopening prime primary school
year groups are going back to school on
the 1st of June
what is Labour's position do you think
that should happen we want schools to go
back we want our children to be educated
we know it makes a huge difference to
their lives and we know it's it's good
for inequalities as well to get all our
kids back into school but it has to be
done correctly I've done a survey of
parents in my constituency over 50
percent are saying we're not ready yet
to send our kids back because we need to
see more evidence that this is the right
thing to do and I think the key thing is
for the government
not to play politics with this and to
try and hit one group against the other
we need to bring everyone together the
unions the parent groups the teachers
and the government talk about how to do
this and local government talk about how
to make this work as they have done in
other places and we need to make sure
that that test track and trace system
that the government has promised by the
1st of June to be in place which is the
only way we get out of this situation
that is the way we end lockdown that is
the way we can all go back to some
semblance of normal life that has to be
in place and there are serious questions
about whether the government are rowing
back on what they've promised on that
front so we need to see the work done so
this is what I'm struggling with a
little bit here and you say that you
want schools go back but when it's safe
you say you want to bring everyone
together now I mean no one would
disagree with that but June the first is
a week away
surely you need make some kind of
decisive decision is labor supporting
some primary shifts children going back
to school on June the 1st yes or no well
of course not children are already in
school and my children are because my
husband works in a hospital so the
schools are open what they're worried
about what teachers are worried about
what the unions are worried about is
making sure it's safe and the government
so shoot more children go back to school
on June the 1st we need to make sure
we've got the test track and trace in
place and we need to bring all the
organizations together so they agree how
to do it that is that is the point
because at the moment there is confusion
there are parents saying they're not
going to send their children back there
are some areas saying they're going to
do it some say they won't the government
need to step up build this leadership
vacuum bringing the organizations
together instead of pitting one against
another and find a solution and we need
to be really clear but that test track
and trace is in place on the 1st of June
because that is the thing that is going
to help us all get back to normal